Dr. Zaky Nik's Nigeria Tour on 8th, 9th,
14th, 15th and 16th June venue Anur
Masjid International Center for Islamic
Culture and Education plot 289 Ibraim
Babanga Boulevard opposite British
village Woos, Abuja, Nigeria. Inshallah
on Saturday 8th June 2013 at 11:00 a.m.
witness Dr. Zakir Nay's comparative
analysis in public on concept of God in
major world religions on Sunday 9th June
2013 at 3:30 p.m. Watch Dr. Zakin Naik
enlighten the public on similarities
between Islam and Christianity.
Venue Sky Pavilion at Abola House Opiia
Lagos Nigeria. Inshallah on Friday 14th
June 2013 at 3:30 p.m. join Farik Zakir
Nay son of Dr. Zakir Nay in his public
presentation on religion in the right
perspective followed by an open question
and answer session by Dr. Zakir Naik on
Saturday 15th June 2013 at 10:00 a.m.
Join Dr. Zakin Nike in his apt analysis
in public on Salah the programming
towards righteousness on Sunday 16th
June 2013 at 10:00 a.m. witness Dr.
Zakin Knight's insightful critique in
public on media and Islam war for peace.
It's a unique opportunity not to be
missed.
Dr. The Zakir Malik's Nigeria tour.